[Musik]
zum tagesgespräch bei phoenix begrüße
ich ganz herzlich marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses des bundestages
größe in berlin
strack-zimmermann können sie mich hören
ja ich kann sie wunderbar ich grüße sie
ganz herzlich in berlin
die
strategie putins fangen wir mal damit an
wir haben noch eine ganze menge mehr zu
reden haben sie den eindruck sie
verändert sich gerade er verändert ist
gerade auch vor dem hintergrund dass ich
jetzt wie wir gerade eine kollegin sagte
das wetter bessert und die luftangriffe
damit vielleicht zu nehmen könnten
die frage ist ja ob er überhaupt eine
strategie hatte er ging davon aus in
drei vier tagen die ukraine zu schlagen
und er wird eines besseren belehrt und
die tragödie ist ja jetzt dass er gar
keine militärischen ziele mehr im auge
hat sondern ausschließlich zivilisten
zivilisten umbringen will und das ist
wirklich eine entmenschlichung in einer
form und lassen sie mich auch sagen die
sprachen und haben uns geeinigt von
putins spree krieg zu sprechen ich sehe
das heute anders ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass nicht teile der
russischen gesellschaft in russland
sehen dass da gerade passiert und die
russische nation muss sich darüber im
klaren werden ob sie einen präsidenten
unterstützt der in dieser form ein
massenmord begeht an unschuldigen
menschen also kann man wie ihr kollege
im bundestag kiesewetter sagt
verhandlungen mit putin als zwecklos
betrachten überhaupt grundsätzlich in
diesem fall für den möglichst
möglicherweise zu finden in frieden und
auch in zukunft
man sollte verhandlungen nie
ausschließen weil es immer die hoffnung
ist dass man doch eine einigung hat aber
wenn man die bilder sieht wenn man die
mitteilungen ließ die wir bekommen dann
möchte er den kompletten fall der
ukraine möchte dieses volk wenn es denn
ihm nicht zu jubelt auslöschen ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass eine
verhandlung mit putin etwas bringt das
ist tragisch weil man ihn nur an seinen
taten messen kann und eben nicht an
seinen worten das haben wir ja auch im
vorfeld schon erlebt er will
offensichtlich eine totale vernichtung
und das muss uns klar sein diese form
der entmenschlichung ist natürlich für
zivilisierte menschen sehr schwer
wahrzunehmen das fasst man ja alles gar
nicht aber wir sollten aufhören naiv zu
sein und gab blauäugig zu sein zu naiv
und blauäugig gehört auch dass wir
sehen müssen dass wir vielleicht nicht
mehr tun können als nur die sanktionen
immerhin die sanktionen aber militärisch
und mit ausrüstung können wir nicht mehr
helfen oder
wir sind hier eingebettet in die nato
wir sind ja nicht alleine die
bundesrepublik deutschland es ist ein
großartiges zeichen dass präsident biden
nach polen reisen will das von ganz
europa und den vereinigten staaten
waffen geliefert werden übrigens auch
von deutschland und insofern dass die
ukraine diesbezüglich wirklich man kann
schon fast sagen weltweit unterstützt
wird das ist so das ist auch richtig so
und präsident selensky bittet um mehr um
mehr unterstützung auch mehr waffen und
waffensysteme nun hört man von der
bundeswehr da ist das was man abgeben
könnte aufgebraucht das ist alles weg es
ist nichts mehr da was können wir denn
noch tun
es geht ja jetzt nicht nur noch um den
bestand der bundeswehr es geht ja darum
dass wir als bundesrepublik natürlich
auch waffensysteme militärisches
material
kaufen können und dieses liefern können
sollte man eigentlich grundsätzlich über
diese waffenlieferungen oder was auch
immer dorthin gebracht wird in die
ukraine öffentlich reden derzeit nein
das sollte man natürlich nicht sie
ergreifen gewissermaßen vor nein das
geht natürlich nicht
dort herrscht krieg und all das material
was benötigt wird muss dorthin
transportiert muss dort umgeschlagen
werden und wir müssen einfach aufhören
in der öffentlichkeit erstes mal darüber
zu diskutieren welche waffensysteme
plötzlich ich bekomme auch e mails von
menschen die mir nun erklären welche
waffensysteme besonders wirkungsvoll
sind das geht nicht sondern das muss in
einer gewissen weise diskret passieren
denn wir gefährden ja auch diejenigen
die diese waffen dorthin transportieren
also insofern an der stelle sollten wir
alle sie als berichterstatter wir in der
politik und zwar wirklich etwas
zurücknehmen es wird sehr sehr viel
getan in einer sehr sehr ernsten
situation
wenn sie das hat meine frage kümmern wir
uns mal ganz kurz nach um uns hier auch
hierzulande das ist ja nun auch ihre
aufgabe mit die bundeswehr sich zu
betrachten und in die zukunft zu blicken
sie sagen die bundeswehr müsse jetzt
sich wieder stärker auf ihre
kernaufgabe konzentrieren nämlich die
verteidigung deutschlands und der nato
bündnispartner
ist dass die neue
zukunftsstrategie und wie sieht sie aus
die neue sicherheitsstrategie für
deutschland
na ja letzteres bündnis und
landesverteidigung wurde eigentlich
festgeschrieben bereits 20 16 im
weißbuch auf grund der aktion der krim
die seinerzeitige bundesregierung hat
das aber eben nur eins weiß buch
geschrieben aber nicht ihren worten
taten folgen lassen und insofern eine
sicherheitsstrategie zu entwickeln
bedeutet auf der einen seite residenz zu
sein das heißt eine starke bundeswehr zu
haben und ich bin nicht nur den
bundeskanzler sondern auch christian
lindner dem finanzminister dankbar dass
diese 100 milliarden sondervermögen bald
hoffentlich auf den weg gebracht werden
dass wir also unsere bundeswehr stärken
aber sicherheitsstrategie bedeutet
natürlich sich auch mit den problemen
weltweit auseinanderzusetzen was führt
eigentlich zur verwerfung was führt
eigentlich zu kriegen das ist ein dickes
brett gebohrt wird es ist aber ein
erwachen auch aus der situation heraus
dass wir alle auch die europäer geglaubt
haben alles bleibt ruhig alles ist gut
auch die warnsignale das muss man auch
selbstkritisch sehen die uns die letzten
jahre ja vor augen geführt worden die
offensichtlich nicht ernst genommen
haben und das liegt natürlich auch daran
was ich vorhin sagte dass diese völlige
entmenschlichung es gibt ja auch regeln
im krieg dass die überhaupt keine rolle
mehr spielen für jeden menschen der noch
ein bisschen herz und seele hat nicht
mehr nachvollziehbar ist und diese hart
dieser diese brutalität der wir jetzt
ausgesetzt sind dem müssen wir uns
stellen das werden wir als
bundesregierung tun und dann eben
entsprechende antworten finden
militärisch ökonomisch auch
gesellschaftlich ganz kurzer blick nach
china haben sie das im focus oder warten
wird er alle wieder ab und gucken was
passiert
wie sehen sie das
naja die nato hat eine strategie oder
arbeitete einer strategie wo natürlich
china eine rolle spielt die ehemalige
nato strategie wir sind eurem russland
sozusagen an unserer seite und china war
überhaupt nicht im fokus das ist vorbei
weil auch die rolle chinas momentan ja
okay sie haben in bei der un enthalten
wir wissen aber dass putin nichts macht
ohne dass die chinesen nicht grünes
licht geben insofern müssen wir uns auch
damit beschäftigen was sicherheit
betrifft das betrifft natürlich auch die
ökonomischen verbindungen der der markt
in china ist für uns ein riesiger markt
das heißt auch unsere wirtschaft muss
sich darüber im klaren sein mit wem
haben wir es da eigentlich zu tun und
auch da müssen wir grenzen ziehen ich
glaube wirklich dass wir viele dinge neu
bedenken müssen das ist nicht einfach
weil es und das kürze weiter zu auch
unser leben in europa in deutschland
verändern könnte die gewissheiten sind
kompletter hin und wir müssen uns
gemeinsam mit der bevölkerung dieser
situation stellen und ich appelliere
auch dass wir in der politischen
verantwortung auch diese bundesregierung
die bevölkerung mitnimmt wir dürfen
nicht so tun als ob dieser krieg nur
zehn stunden von uns entfernt uns hier
nichts anginge er geht uns nicht nur
emotional etwas an wir sehen ja die
vielen vertriebenen die vielen
flüchtlinge die auch unter anderem in
berlin ankommen sondern es betrifft auch
unser leben unsere abhängigkeit
ökonomischen abhängigkeit da gibt es
viel zu diskutieren und wir täten gut
daran jeden mann jede frau mitzunehmen
deutschland und klar zu machen dass die
gewissheiten der letzten jahrzehnte die
gewissheiten nach 1945 von der wir
ausgehen es gibt keine glanz
verschiebung mehr es werden keine
grenzen mehr infrage gestellt dass die
tragischerweise vorbei sind und wir
sollten uns gemeinsam auf den weg machen
überparteilich um uns dieser situation
zu stellen schluss mit der blaue des
körpers sagt marie agnes strack
zimmermann danke schön für das gespräch
dann kann nach berlin ich danke ihnen